[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
okay so we have a special guest here
today let me tell you who it is so think
about the following imagine you're
having a uh intense conversation with
your spouse she's asking you questions
you don't know how to answer them your
your parents are interrogating you
you're going through all these series of
questions a client is asking you
questions about a product you're getting
stuck on imagine being this is a job I
really want you to think about this for
a second before I uh you know we get
right into it imagine being the former
press secretary for the White House
for President George W bush from let's
listen to the dates January of 01 to
July of 03 we're talking 9 11 and every
day you're looking at this person on the
big screen being questioned on every
single small move being made and that is
your job that's how you make a living
that person is on the podcast today Ari
Fleischer thank you so much for making
the time for being here today Beth
thanks for having me glad to be here
that's a tough job man how do you do
what you do that's not an easy job yeah
it was easy reporters throw softball
questions at you they love Republicans
they love Bush easy job of course if Joe
Bush was loved you know the Republicans
were always loved and the Press is fair
to the Republicans so but I'm actually
curious because I watch it and by the
way our buddy Adam is not here right now
let me tell you guys why Adam lives in
this retirement community called Miami
and uh you know this retirement
community in Miami they go on a
different time sometimes and he still is
living the lifestyle of the
anti-retirement community which I'm sure
you know you may be a little bit
familiar with and so he had some other
appointments late night last night but
he's on his way he should be here with
us any moment when he does Tyler you can
open the door he'll come in he'll join
us and uh I hope there's no video of
those appointments nah he he keeps that
private he's pretty discreet about it he
uses signal to communicate with them so
the message disappears so are Ari going
into uh uh obviously we're going to
cover a lot of different issues you just
wrote a book called deception snobbery
and biased we got a lot of things to
cover uh Trump uh the santis uh musk I
don't know if you're following the
sandbankment free uh there's a lot of
things going on right now in America
a lot of complexities the device that
makes last time I'm having dinner with
uh uh David Solomon CEO of Goldman Sachs
and we're they're having dinner and you
know we're in Miami and questions are
being brought up what about this and
what about that and what about even his
saying he's I've never seen this device
before you know on on how America is
it's pretty intense what are your
opinions about divisiveness where we are
today is this the worst you've ever seen
or is this pretty normal
oh boy it's a yes to all the above
really
um yeah this is the worst I've ever seen
in my lifetime but it's been worse in
America's lifetime if you ask historians
election of 1800 between Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams was way worse
than this much more acrimonious the
accusations they launched again way
worse than this correct I mean back then
you used to call people whoremongers you
would attack their wives I mean it was
personal nasty can you give us specific
stories examples well Andrew Jackson in
1828 I believe it was uh he when he ran
for president he was accused of bigamy
because the divorce that his wife Rachel
had hadn't gone through it the Pony
Express hadn't dropped off the papers in
essence wow and so he married Rachel
before the divorce went through and so
he was called a bigamist Rachel was
called a big Ms she died during the
transition before he took office in 1829
and people said that she died of a
heartache uh in politics in America has
always been the noisy sport
and back in the old days it was all done
through pamphleteers with the nastiest
most personal things said about each
other we went through a much longer
phase where it kind of got cleaned up
I remember George H.W bush in the 1992
race against uh Bill Clinton at the end
of their race under all the pressure in
late October George H.W bush called Bill
Clinton
clown and the Press went nuts how can
you call him that how can you use such
language over the word clown and look
where we are today yeah clown today is a
soft uh it's a compliment today versus
what you know some things that are being
said today so but but let me maybe let
me ask this question in a different way
so now election wise what has changed
like what uh you know how we go back and
look at uh if I talk to Rudy Giuliani
he'll say well let me tell you what we
did back in the days The Recoil loss we
changed to go after the mob okay great
well let me tell you what happened in
America right after 9 11 you know TSA
going into the airport that was a
dramatic thing November of 01 when we
changed it and you go into TSA you
should be able to go in there now you
have to do this and you got to get your
TSA Pre and clear on it's a lot of
things have changed right so certain
laws changed or Patriot Act we're going
to get into some of that stuff but
election wise what's changed with
election over the years yeah but I trace
it back to the end of Bush's
Administration the one I worked for
George W bush
and as a result of the war in Iraq and
how
this divisive the war became and the
opposition to Bush over the war became
the Democrats started to call him a war
criminal now I never previously heard I
was just referring to George H.W bush
calling somebody a clown and being
criticized all of a sudden you're a war
criminal attorney general Al Gonzalez
you're a war criminal the language the
tone things just start to change social
media is now invented it didn't exist
when I was in office it came at the end
of the Bush years and into the Obama
years that allowed people just to let it
rip with no filter and people said the
meanest nastiest things on social media
and that just became part of the
parlance that enveloped us as opposed to
the older decorum where people said show
some respect don't say those things keep
your thoughts to yourself those
old-fashioned Notions sticks and stones
and then it got worse Obama comes into
office and certainly he was divisive
president he had very low regard for
Republicans Republicans had low regard
for him Donald Trump of course said he
wasn't born here which was wrong he said
he was born in Kenya which was wrong
it just starts the it continued it
snowballed and now again social media
piles on top of it where people agree to
these things
and then it just continued on and then
when Trump's win Trump wins in 2016 and
half of America becomes unhinged and
says it's because of Russia collusion
and and the whole Trump's illegitimate
and for all the criticism of Republicans
being election deniers which is a valid
criticism
it was started by the Democrats in 2016
when they never accepted Donald Trump's
election
so all of this has made a pitted America
pitted camps I'm a Believer though Pat
in the pendulum swings in this country
and it always swings back toward the
center always back to reasonableness and
moderation because that's the
temperament of the American people we're
going through a phase we're going
through a swinging phase you think we're
going to go back to being diplomatic
like you think because the one thing is
there anything that's not going to
change is there anything that's going to
change I think like what I think is
going to change hey we're going to go
left oh my God we're going too far ah
we're gonna go right oh we're going too
far right oh we're going to go I think
that part may be right but are we you
know at a point where you know how they
say well the first time you have sex and
you lose your virginity it's like
they're in that second third nobody and
then it's like oh let it rip you know
you just you're single you're you're not
even thinking about it and what's a
completely different story but the first
time is the first time then it becomes
normal are we living in the trolling era
where this uh Jake Paul This Dana White
this Conor McGregor Gregor Trump Elon
Musk where trolls are winning so it's
becoming a Playbook to say I have to
learn how to troll not that these folks
are trolls they're learning how to troll
they're learning how to poke and schools
and but you know if you go to regular
debate a class you take they don't teach
you on how to handle trolls they don't
teach you on those kinds of things they
say well when you debate you have to
respect your opponent and you have to go
based on this and then all of a sudden
boom atrocious of you don't know how to
address that do you think the trolling
is here that's not going away and a name
calling and all of that or are we
gradually going to go back to being
extremely diplomatic to each other we
are living through a very vituperative
era trolls and just the breakdown of
old-fashioned treat people with dignity
and respect even if you disagree with
their opinions
the solution to that is easy one day a
leader will run for president who
actually means it and can rise up and
unite people
we have politicians who run now saying
I'm a uniter I won't do this or I won't
do that then they get into office and
right away get divisive
we're going to get sick of this and one
day a president's going to tap into that
and a president who is genuinely
somebody who people respect he treats
people with dignity he looks at the
other party and says I disagree with
your ideas I'm going to defeat you on
your ideas
but I respect the fact that you love
this country too and that is the
Hallmark of America we have always had a
level of unity acceptance tolerance that
unites us As Americans makes us the Envy
of the world and a Ronald Reagan style
candidate who comes out and reminds
people about what this country the city
on a hill can be like is going to have a
huge following
by temperament not necessarily by
ideology by temperament because we can
get tired of the vituperative era and
the Pendulum will swing I think so you
think you think it's good I do so so
give me uh uh I know everybody says uh
you know we need another Ronald Reagan
to show up right and we need another you
know John F Kennedy Democrats will say
we need a Clinton temperament to show up
because how you was well then Obama
showed up but do you think
um a person like that can show up and
take all the constant criticism and get
the media to turn around and be kind and
gentle and soft to them not about the
media it's about the country it's about
the people yes I believe that the the
thing about the presidency and whoever
emerges to run for president
they single-handedly have the ability to
set an example this is what presidents
do and when the example like President
sets is to belittle is to continue the
vituperative streak that our nation is
in the middle of people follow
when a president actually Rises up and
people read it and see it and believe
that this guy actually does focus on
Unity
even if he ideologically he's different
from you or me
that president has a chance that's
leadership it's about leadership I I
don't I don't disagree so so let me let
me like when I watch you
you know you're taking all those
questions right and I uh I went back and
watched some of the old stuff I even
watch it with Chris Matthews back in the
days you know the Christmas movies back
and forth and hey you know you're doing
this and you're doing all this and
you're like that's an unfair question
would you also ask that question that
happened under Obama's watch you're
gonna blame him as well and he says
that's fair and he takes it back and
kind of moves on but
for somebody to do what you do
and to sit there and get the constant
criticism to tough questions is that
duplicatable
or is that just purely uh uh in the
individual's psyche DNA that maybe
somebody can get a little bit better uh
in the area of answering the tough
questions but there's got to be a part
of it that's your personality your
temperament to do that because that's
not an easy job specifically during the
time that you did it that's a very very
difficult time to do that do you think
someone can learn how to do that or some
of that is natural
I think a lot of it is temperament you
have to one enjoy the Press you really
do you have to look at that briefing
room as a fun place to stand your ground
and you have to respect the fact that
under our first amendment the Press can
ask whatever damn well pleases and
that's their job
and just because you get asked a hard
question doesn't mean you have to
struggle you can give a hard answer in
return sometimes you can give a fun
answer in Return of poke fun at
reporters it's just how you do it but
what it comes down to is enjoying it
respecting the process respecting the
Press but standing your ground on behalf
of what you believe in and what the
president is advocating for that's what
makes the job really fun how much of it
do you uh is it like anticipation you
take out you know like you see the
current one you know it's a whole folder
you know and sacky and many of these
that they had these okay what question
are you asking okay I got eight seconds
to go to the page yeah on what it is and
then they just read it oh would you ask
okay can you go into it over here no let
me see what he said how much of it is
preparation to say uh like are you
sitting with a group of people saying
okay guys what do you think they're
going to be asking us Ari they're going
to ask about this okay let's role play
if they ask you this what's your answer
going to be I'm probably going to say
something this avoid that word say this
I wouldn't say that that will attack you
if you say this and then which which
ones are we working on we're looking at
all these people you know those three
can't stand you you know those three uh
ask softball questions you know those
three you like but they ask tough
questions is I'm assuming all of it
you're a sports guy I'm assuming their
strategy to the madness as well no there
is but there's also fundamentals go back
to sports if your swing's no good it
doesn't matter how much time you take be
pay if your mechanics are wrong you're
not gonna be able to improve that much
the single the most important way to
handle that job you can't speak for the
president if you don't listen to the
president so the way to prep is you got
to be in the Oval Office all the time I
was in almost all the president's
meetings I'd spend a third a quarter of
my day in the oval listening to what he
listened to hearing what he said and
then you take that so now you've got
knowledge you know what the president's
doing then you take that and yeah you do
get your staff before you go out and
prep before you brief and you say fire
away what are they going to ask me today
and sometimes you go okay I got that one
I got it I got it got it all right whoa
let's talk about that one that one's a
curveball what are we going to say on
that one call the Secretary of Defense I
need to answer on this call your
spokesman spokesperson at the Department
of Transportation get me more info so it
all goes into it but again
the essential ingredient to surviving
that room is having fun you know I
looked at it like it was intellectual
chess I'd go in there going if I say a I
can make them ask question B and I was
already thinking of answers C knowing I
could take them to question yeah and I
thrived on that
um go back to sports that room was my
field and I was never going to let the
Press beat me on my field and so I
looked at it like a sport like
competition knowing what questions they
were going to ask because you try to
anticipate sure so my hardest stays
frankly
or slow newsdays if there was a major
crisis if something was terrible going
on on September 11th I knew every
question was going to be about what did
Bush do what did Bush said yeah
September 11th
frankly from just a briefing point of
view those days were simpler and easier
wow because I knew every question coming
and I knew the answers
the slow news days nothing's really big
nothing's going on 25 topics that's the
hardest what a great perspective to
think about so it is more predictable
the the more crisis there is because you
know what this 80 of the questions are
going to be and the less crisis there is
you don't know what's going to be Adam
thanks for joining us I'm glad you made
it thank you sir Howard how are your
appointments tonight I uh the retirement
community sends their love especially to
you Mr Fleischer from Love from uh down
in Miami but yeah of the two of us I
guarantee you had a more wild night than
I did I guarantee that really did I
stayed home the way you say that I mean
some people are going to say Pat's
married how Wild of a night did he have
you had dinner at an amazing place I'd
had a good dinner I came home and I I
even text you and I'm like this place is
wild I gotta leave but uh yes but going
back but going back to it what you said
very important uh uh question so you
said hey I'm I was never gonna let them
beat me right at their game and you know
give me your biggest victory during that
time and and the day that they maybe
whooped your butt a little bit what
would be the two you know
the biggest quote-unquote victory was
after September 11th in the lead up to
the war in Afghanistan I'll never forget
this there was a front page store in USA
Today saying Special Forces deployed to
Afghanistan and this is before the first
shot was fired before anything took
place
and your special forces and who's in the
Army the Army I almost went into special
I thought you were a ranger I was a
101st Airborne Arab is what I was yeah
okay well I interviewed you're very
closely of Special Forces I was down the
street from them yes that's why if I
would have reenlisted I would have gone
into Special Forces so the story was
special forces Rangers deployed to
Afghanistan and live at the briefing and
this briefing is covered on live TV
everywhere Al Jazeera is covering it
live I get asked to confirm whether or
not we sent Special Forces but over the
ground troops before the Before the War
Began
and I looked at the reporter and I said
you know under our system you have the
right to ask me anything you want
I have the responsibility not to answer
next question
and I kind of feel America cheering for
me when I said that answer
because yeah the Press is going to ask
for deployment information they want to
know about the movement of our ships and
our troops in advance of a war
as if I'm going to tell him anything of
course I'm not going to tell him
anything
but it's such a funny dichotomy because
every reporter in the room was pissed at
me how come you won't answer that
question but I knew everybody in America
was cheering for me because they didn't
want me to answer that question and
that's when it was just so crystal clear
to me that my job sometimes is to speak
over the heads of reporters and say what
the president wanted me to say to the
people and that's that was in many ways
my you know called it Victory so so uh
follow up with uh this next question is
when your
you know let's just say you have a you
have a two or three kids you got four
kids
and your personality okay you go to
school and you're somebody that's a
powerful person and people have opinions
about your father okay you go to say
well your dad oh did you see your dad is
all of this
all he cares about is money did you see
what he did to these immigrants did you
see what they did to that and did you
see what and as a kid let's just say
your your brain is still at a point
where you're kind of like maybe that
teacher was right maybe that kid was
right is my dad really a bad person is
my mom really a bad person they're kind
of messing with you and you're coming
home you're like well he's good to me I
see how he is with me I see how he
treats my mind I see how he treats
things are good but man why are they
saying all these bad things about him
right okay so if you're working with
President Bush or if you're working with
President Trump or anybody
you're working with President Bush
Michael Moore comes out with Fahrenheit
11. okay
you're working with Obama Dinesh de
Souza comes up with uh Obama's uh
America 4 000 mules two thousand
Millions no no what was the one about
Obama's America or something like that
yeah yeah not not the one about Hillary
because that was a different one but he
did one about Obama's dream or Obama's
America yeah Obama's America 2016. you
know and then hey uh uh you know Richard
Gage who we had him on let me tell you
911 was an inside job you know the BBC
reported that the building's going down
and before any of this stuff and they
knew about it and look at the reaction
when he's reading the book and they're
talking to the kids and he knew what was
going on look at the way he reacted to
it and the camera's on and everybody's
watching and you know so and let me tell
you how Trump is did you guys hear Trump
is doing this and did you see Trump's
documentary and all the bankruptcies and
this is one of the worst businessmen of
all time and it doesn't matter what side
you're on right I'm just saying this is
you know Obama's on the inside you're at
bushes on the inside you're Trump's on
on the inside how do you working with
him and you're in the meetings you're
seeing things that's going on and you're
seeing all of that
how are you balancing it out to know
that you're probably when you go into a
restaurant I'm assuming during that time
if it's 2001 2002 2003 I'm just willing
to bet if you're going to a restaurant
and and you're there with your wife I'm
sure not everybody comes up and says are
you awesome man what's up dude you
killed it today that was amazing right
I'm sure there's some of it that's
coming up and saying you know how dare
you you know representing a president
like that how how do you not uh crack
and break when others are trying to get
you to pin you against the person you're
working with how do you manage that it's
easy frankly number one bush had really
thick skin so it didn't bother him and
when it doesn't bother the boss it tends
not to bother the staff now if it
bothers the boss or your boss is thin
skin throws stuff how do they do that
why they report that the men you're
under pressure yeah he wasn't yeah so I
didn't have to be
uh secondly I believe when the the most
beautiful thing about the White House
and I don't care what party you are yeah
is when you believe
it is so easy to fight
and stand your ground and you take the
incoming you try to pay attention maybe
you'll learn something from the incoming
you can rebutt it stronger learn you got
a vulnerability maybe we should address
this
but you take the incoming and you turn
it around because you believe
and that's how democracy should work if
I can't stand there and explain what the
president is doing and why he's doing it
and if I can't do it articulately and we
take incoming then maybe we deserved it
but if I can explain it and say it
articulately and drive more support for
it that's the job
I love that how different was he I had
the uh opportunity to uh invite him to
an event which was I saw the picture
right I had the opportunity to write him
to the event and that was in 20 2019
same event we had Kobe Bryant delayed
Kobe Bryant at and I had President Bush
there and he I'm coming out of the
bathroom he's coming to the bathroom
it's the first time we make the
connections like hey hey Patrick I'm
going to wait for you over there okay
great he goes to the bathroom comes back
a bunch of people there with the Secret
Service sticker and you know and then we
had a nice 45 minute conversation in the
back talking to him and then on stage
when I interviewed him telling the
stories opening up and when we announced
him being a keynote speaker it was not
like I'll remember we're at a hotel in
Dallas and I announced our two keynote
speakers and the first one I'm just
watching and I said guys I want to find
out the reaction so put the camera on
them there's about of 1500 people there
and we're announcing it that's going to
be at Mirage is going to be 6 000 people
there so I said okay
first Speaker we're gonna have at the
event it runs the cameras ready they're
live President George W bush
what the reactions were Priceless
dumbfounded and some were like oh my God
our president's coming but it was a very
different and then I said hey you know
Kobe Bryant they lost their mind right
and they were so excited anyways
President Bush comes up and I interview
him and he talks personal life what
things he did what things he changed
just being very open about the whole
thing and then we're doing pictures
succession with pictures
and I cannot tell you how many people
who were you know not supportive and
send me messages you shouldn't have
brought them you shouldn't have done
this they're like look I don't know if I
agree with policies but I like the guy I
kind of like him on how he is you know
wow I like this guy this would be a guy
I would want to have dinner with what I
I like and then so every time everybody
was taking a picture half of them were
happy to take the picture the other half
were like I gotta tell you I thought
look one girl said I thought you were
the Antichrist but I like talking to you
this was amazing listening to you thank
you so much for coming out how was he
off camera behind closed doors was he
funny was he a Storyteller was he a
prankster was he always serious was
there a topic he always wanted to study
like is he a guy that studied Andrew
Jackson did he have a favorite President
that he would always read about is there
a certain book he would he play
backgammon is he a Domino's guy is he a
chess guy what was he like like you know
the clip on Last Dance you know you see
the security guy coming in come on one
more time yeah rolling a dice 20 bucks
boom he beats Michael and he goes like
this right and he does the Michael thing
back at him and Michael's pissed off
what was he like off stage off camera
I've heard what you said so many times
from people who have seen him in his
post-presidency
he is gregarious he's engaging he's
self-deprecating he's witty as can be
and funny and fun he was a great boss I
don't care what you industry you're in
or what ideology you have you want a
boss like George W bush he was inspiring
he was tough you were going to work your
tail off for him you never want to let
him down but boy was he a good guy who
was loyal and took care of you and you
in exchange gave him your loyalty
because that's the kind of relationship
of Boston and gender in any industry
um but yeah he was uh he was a towel
Snapper witty lots of jokes you know he
would keep things light now after
September 11th that went away for quite
a while but that's his nature and and it
came back
um he has a marvelous touch that
inspires people through seriousness and
humor
in his post-presidency and I've done
many of these events and speeches with
him where you know to moderate a q a
um people get to see his humor and you
saw it there I'm sure you know and most
of it's self-deprecating most of it
makes fun of himself yeah it's very hard
for some people to do that you can't do
it and I I got to tell you for me uh I
love comedy I think comedy is amazing if
I have to say like uh you know when when
you say 128 months of economic expansion
you know during the whatever era was it
Obama and Trump era you know economy was
the best when it was growing it was so
awesome interest rates this I think the
longest standing economic expansion for
comedy was under President Bush I have
to tell you because Will Ferrell Will
Ferrell to me is like hello hello
America this is your uh
commander-in-chief on the world I'm here
in Crawford Texas trying to grow soul
patch and hanging out with Kelly and
Dick we're here to talk about something
that really matters like you know
keeping steroids out of t-ball and are
you just watching this I've seen that
thing I don't know how many times and
you know what I'm like about him is he
would say this one guy said yeah he is
my favorite comedian impersonator
because at some point like you have to
laugh at yourself and if you can't laugh
at yourself these guys are not going to
slow down but this he's I mean this if
you look at this picture right here of a
Will Ferrell and President Bush I mean
this guy crushed it just a couple days
ago I watched Will Ferrell's uh first uh
SNL you and Vinnie were showing it to me
but uh
for comedy I think uh during Meyer at
least I think he's the goat when it
comes on to Comedy and people
impersonating him did you guys watch
that did you talk about that would he
joke about that what'd he say hey so Ari
what did you think about that he
wouldn't watch it but he was aware of it
okay and he would laugh when somebody
would say to him here's what they said
about you last night he would laugh you
know the whole thing where he used the
word strategory instead of strategy
as soon as he said that we as a staff
started calling our meeting strategy
meetings yeah and he liked it
because again the guy's got thick skin
and a sense of humor so you could do
that to him
I have a question hi Ari
um you know we have a lot of
conversations about Legacy whether you
you know can create your own legacy or
whether you can do your best or whether
the world you know gives you your legacy
you know
when George W bush came into office just
Side Story I was in Tallahassee Florida
a senior year of college 2000 2001. I
hope your Chads didn't hang no right I
was I was working uh as an intern at the
Capitol this was during the election
this was right during 9 11 and I I who
was the governor of Florida at the time
Jeb Bush so I was very familiar with the
but I wasn't a big political person at
the time and I was there I was I was
seeing all this and you know his
especially during um 911 his approval
ratings went up to 80 something percent
the highest we've seen in in Forever uh
but to my question about Legacy you know
these days you don't see a lot of them
like when you do see them as far as
being a nice guy like that exchange he
had with Michelle Obama when he gave her
a piece of candy and like they're kind
of they're being nice and friendly and
uh you know he still hangs out with even
the clintons and he hangs you know he's
kind of has that
um obviously the the bush
Legacy and trumps are they're not
exactly seeing eye to eye
um but at the end of the day where do
you think the Bush family Legacy will
end up living I mean his father was a
president his brother ran for president
governor this is a legacy family uh and
he essentially was the Pinnacle of it
right last president where do you see
the Bush family Legacy and specifically
his legacy well since he left office
he's become more popular he left office
I'm sad to say is one of the most
unpopular presidents we've ever had his
approval rating was in the low 30s yeah
I mean it um yeah right and that was
Iraq and it's now people have really
appreciated the way he has handled
himself how he doesn't criticize the
incumbent president Trump or Obama or
Biden because as he puts it the job's
hard enough and I'm not going to add to
their burdens he wants to put the
country first
now and people appreciate that
um
his legacy will still come down to Iraq
in many ways and the history the future
of Iraq is still being written I do
think it is one of the well it is the
only Arab democracy in existence right
now
and it's a rough democracy it certainly
is not a western style United States
France Germany democracy yet
but it is on the path
unlike any other Arab Middle East nation
and this is tremendously important so I
think it's going to come down to that
and this is where people are going to
say
um was it worth it
but there's one in inescapable fact and
that was we turned out to be wrong about
wmd and the information that the
president had uh which was the world's
conclusion that Saddam had wmd turned
out to be wrong and we acted on wrong
information
and that is still going to be something
that historians write about I believe to
this day that if the CIA had said to
George Bush we're not sure he may have
wmd he may not we really don't know
I don't think he would have gone to war
with Iraq he wouldn't have done it
unless he was convinced they had wmd he
was convinced because that was what the
intelligence information said right as
far as blame goes I mean I think we look
back at 9 11 what a tragic day the war
in Iraq Afghanistan you know Biden just
pulled us out if you know I'm not trying
to like shift blame or put blame on
anyone but are you saying that it's
essentially the intelligence community's
fault that bush believed them or what
percentage does he have to own up to it
what percentages he made the decision to
go to war based on the belief that
Saddam had wmd as I said I think if he
had gotten other information he would
not have gone a war
um but there's no question about it it
was the world's intelligence communities
that all reached that same conclusion it
wasn't just the CIA it was Egyptian
intelligence French intelligence Israeli
intelligence all of them believed that
Saddam had stockpiles of chemical and
biological weapons not nuclear but
chemical and biological
amazingly Saddam threw out the weapons
inspectors destroyed the stockpiles that
he did indeed have and hit it and one of
the reasons we were so wrong about this
was Saddam put up a fake front to
deceive Iran
he wanted Iran to believe that he had
wmd as a deterrence to Iran a nation
that's Iraq and Iran fought Wars and so
he created this whole web of deluge of
Illusion of clandestine activities
moving things secret Communications
which of course our intelligence
Services pick up on and we reached the
conclusion aha see he's got it it was a
bluff to Iran after he actually did get
rid of his wmd which he would not tell
anybody that he got rid of it so that's
why the world intelligence communities
reached that conclusion our question for
you so at the time George Tenet was the
director of CIA right correct but he was
not nominated by President Bush he was
nominated by Clinton he was Clinton's
CIA so why would he keep him though is
it why would he not fire okay so let me
kind of play a little bit of a devil's
advocate so this is a game of Legacy
game okay so if you're playing a legacy
and it's a very competitive game very
very competitive game in the darkest way
and there is no Leader's bulletin the
only leaders bulletin you have is who
has a worse reputation who has a bigger
Legacy who has a better Victory that's
how you compete in football touchdowns
Super Bowls Brady's got seven you don't
he's the goat you know Jordan's got six
LeBron you got four you know he played
1089 games and averaged 32 points a game
30 points a game you did not you were
1500 games the other day I watched a
statistic comparing John Stockton's uh
Legacy of a consistency to LeBron James
do you know how many 82 season games
LeBron's had won do you know how many
John Stockton's had it was like 18 of
see that's just some some ludicrous
number on what he did like oh my God so
we can track Legacy based on stats okay
now LeBron's got Championship Stockton's
got zero so he can't brag about that
part but
why why the the
George tenet's loyalty isn't to Bush yes
you may say well no he's an American his
loyalties to the country and it's to
American it's this it's a part of it's
like it's inside so you're given Intel
the rest of us are watching the movie
Vice and you know you watch the movie
Vice you watch all these movies The W
there's so many movies that you read
about I've read decision points I've
read the book on the family what Bush
family stands for Prescott and what they
did and I gave him a gift from his uh
grandfather Prescott's one of their
buttons and about a bunch of different
things and I give him as a gift the
Legacy that you first go make your money
and then you take care of your family
and kids and then you give back to the
country and you run for office or
something like that's a very uh a lot of
things I pulled from that family's
Legacy to want to apply to my own family
but one why keep the same director of
CIA who was Nam who was nominated and
chosen by Democrat you're Republican why
not replace them with somebody's nobody
would say anything to you if you pick
somebody else and two you know when you
see a lot of uh the things that happen
with Vice and how well you know they
went to war because this was a great
business decision there's a lot of money
when you go to war you know look at Dick
Cheney and look at the the Donald's
Rumsfeld and look at some of the darkest
people in America and who they are and
et cetera Etc and
that's what the story is told right so
one why keep ten of two you know the
Legacy that we read about where the
motive behind it was money he kept
tenant because he viewed the CIA as a
non-political position it wasn't the
type of thing he needed a loyalist he
wanted somebody who was good in
intelligence and who had a steady hand
you think like would you advise let's
just say I become a president it depends
on who the person is if and he hit it
off with tenet during the transition he
liked tenet got it to a meshed
personality-wise and so George Tenet was
a Democrat he worked for Senator David
Boren who was the chairman of the Senate
intelligence committee he was the chief
of staff on Capitol Hill to David Boren
President Clinton nominated George to be
the CIA director and Bush kept him and
again it was because he thought
continuity was important and it was not
a political position and he liked the
guy so again I mean the cia's
conclusions about wmd didn't begin on
George Bush's watch they had said the
same thing to the previous president to
president uh Clinton about Saddam
um as for legacy Etc
you know Bush never did anything for
legacy and I don't care if people
believe that or not he didn't he did it
because he thought it was the right
reason to protect America and he knew
some of the things he did were
controversial but he did them anyway
because he thought it was the right
thing to do for America
um any of this nonsense about money or
oil or any of that I mean doesn't that
fall into the same trolling vituperative
war criminal stuff we started talking
about earlier it's the same junk it's
the same excess it's the same extremes
speaking out in in a fashion that just
they let it rip and Bush's instructions
to me and the way Bush conducted himself
was to rise above it
he wouldn't let me go to the podium and
fight back on a lot of these things
because he didn't want to engage at that
level yeah and you know one of the
biggest criticisms I hear from president
Trump's supporters Sean Hannity included
and I've talked to Sean about this a lot
is Trump fought back you bushies mccains
Romney's you guys didn't know how to
fight back and you didn't fight back
Trump counter punches and this is a
legitimate difference inside the modern
Republican party how far do you go how
put how much punching should you do how
tough should you get and they said Bush
didn't fight back
is there a better balance like do you
think Bush should have fought more do
you think Trump fights too much is is
there a more moderate approach yeah I
think there's a balance I wrote a op-ed
in the Wall Street Journal when the
midterms for Donald Trump we're using a
football analogy I said the problem with
Donald Trump is every time he gains
yards going down the field he gets a
flag for Unnecessary Roughness or a late
hit so if he gains 100 yards he's
knocked back 65 yards from all these
penalties and I said you can't win the
game that way
um yeah I think there's more of a
balance I I think what happened in the
bush years particularly through the end
of the Bush era the White House staff
got tired everything was just so tough
things in Iraq were so bad
Bush live people died they were too
tired to fight back and they thought
we're not going to get our message
across and I want to remind you back in
that era especially 2006 or so
we only had the mainstream media we
didn't have Twitter we didn't have
YouTube we didn't have social media we
couldn't go around the Press Bush didn't
have followers online
that didn't exist yet so we had to fight
through the New York Times The
Washington Post ABC NBC Fox was a very
different Fox back then so I just think
the White House staff said it doesn't
matter what we say the Press won't cover
us
so all these criticisms of bush matching
his low job approval stuck
so could he have fought back more should
he have fought back more
I was outside the White House at this
point I had fresher legs at that point I
would have loved to have fought more at
that point but for the people inside
they just thought it won't work I want
to show something can you pull this up
because I still want to go back to the
questions director of Center uh CIA okay
go all the way to the bottom go all the
way to the bottom all the way to the
bottom bottom bottom bottom bottom okay
go meaning to yeah go up a little bit
okay so uh uh George W bush okay stay
right there go a little lower on the
bush side
on the bush side yeah so if you look at
this uh he had three directors of CIA
okay one of which was George and he kept
him till all four specifically during
that era which was the issue and then he
replaced them with John okay but that's
not his guy but if you look at the uh uh
Clinton he had five on he had five
directors of CIA I interviewed James
Woolsey he says I don't even know why he
put me in the job because he never
talked to me we only talked twice
so he his director of CIA January 21st
1993 he picked him right stutter uh
stadman stutterman so go up a little bit
to the next one if you keep doing the
same exact exercise uh that we're doing
George H.W bush it's his guy right
William Webster keep going up keep going
up keep going up Reagan his guy Jimmy
Carter his guy General Gerald Ford his
guy if you go to Nixon his guy if you go
to Lyndon Johnson his guy the only
person that didn't have the same
director of CIA as
the prior president as John F Kennedy
John F Kennedy kept it because it was
the same as go up a little bit uh as
Dwight Eisenhower so he says I'm just
going to keep it but I I don't know I
you know you you uh uh you're Elon Musk
you buy Twitter you don't keep the same
you know exact guys that you have
because they don't trust you they
probably don't even like you because in
the business world the people at Twitter
how it was ran before can't stand what
Elon stands for so Elon lets go of how
many people 3 750 people 50 percent of
Salesforce the the workforce what
happens to that 3750 they recruit the
other guys to quit you got another 1250
that resign you're like dude I don't
trust these guys I got to get somebody
anything that trust you know that aligns
with what I'm doing
so I think that my opinion I'm not on
the inside to say whether it's the right
move or not uh I don't know if I would
have done it that way that's my opinion
second
I you know I had a couple Brazilian
people here that I had on the podcast
because I'm really curious to know
what's going on with Brazil one of them
is a is the son of the former uh
president of of uh Brazil Paolo
figuerdio I'm not even sure if I'm
telling the last name right or wrong or
and the other one was Rodrigo
Constantine and I'm talking about Brazil
what's taking place and I had a friend
here Marvin who's from Honduras who
follows politics very closely
and we compared bolsonaro against Lula
okay
um so bolsonaro against Lula Lula has
been in the political world for a long
time bolsonaro is more a doer he's a guy
that's going to go out there and compete
he's allowed they're both allowed one is
louder than the other that's what they
compete for
but who's more Street Smart probably
Lula is more Street Smart than
bolsonares meaning he's wise because
he's been playing dirty for a long time
50 years he can do laps around bolsonaro
on how to play politics so to the people
that say Bush could have been behind it
I don't know if the credibility is if
Bush was behind you know like uh 9 11
for money and all this other stuff but
it can I say a little bit from my own
level of skepticism that maybe there are
somebody on the inside that they
couldn't care less about Legacy they
want to figure out a way how to maximize
their job at the White House to make
money and we have a president today
that's done that you've seen it you've
read it it's been all over the place
that you use that last name in the job
and Clinton's been criticized for that
uh uh he's been criticized for that bite
and a lot of people have been criticized
for that so do some people get in and
use their ability to persuade and I can
only imagine like if there's a meeting
and everybody's sitting there saying
President Bush
there I I I'm we have very strong uh
data that there's weapons of mass
destruction and then you ask the
question what do you think we should do
I think we should attack and you know uh
uh defend uh our country because if we
don't we seem like we're weak and we're
not doing our part and we have to do
something about it right now boom you
come out here you give the message you
know it's like oh my God this is crazy
this is amazing and then later on like
there was no weapons of mass destruction
so maybe somebody manipulated a way to
get somebody to make a decision that
they would have never supported
themselves I don't know if I'm making
sense it's a long-winded question I'm
asking but you don't think somebody that
gets inside has negative motives that
will use it in a way to monetize and
make money because that's what a lot of
people in politics have been criticized
for doing no I don't think so first of
all George Tenet didn't come to the
conclusion that Saddam had wmd the CIA
that his agency did his experts his
analysts
I don't know who the head of Egyptian
intelligence is but he didn't come to
the conclusion his analysts did same
thing with Israel same thing with his
friends Etc he's the guy no yeah but
that's not like they make up the facts
they have their teams of experts who go
and find the facts fine well with find
the allegations find the beliefs the
conclusions that they can put together
but let me let me talk to you about
intelligence generally speaking
one of the things that I learned at the
White House is intelligence is maddening
you know on the TV shows people make it
look like oh my God the envelope just
came in we opened it up and here's the
report from our agent in the field we
got the goods holy take action and then
come the paratroopers
most intelligence reports are mindlessly
frustrating because they're we have
reasons to believe acts but then there's
also why and then we have people who
tell us Z our analysis shows it could be
X Y or Z this is what you get for most
intelligence reports they'll put a
probability on it they say oh our
assessment is the probability leans in
the direction more of X but we don't
discount why you read one of these
things and you're what what what's your
conclusion give me a conclusion that is
why most intelligence reports
like a McKenzie or Gardener you hire
them and they say you know our
assessment is 62 chance this is where
you're losing your money and is it kind
of like that well it's it's more because
the other side North Korea Iran Russia
China gets to hide things
and it's not like we can just walk in
and say give me your stuff you can't
hide it anymore I need to know well
that's the whole game has to be a better
intelligence though yes but my point is
it doesn't always lead itself to a
hundred percent declarative knowledge it
leads itself to surmising believing
taking things and trying to piece it
together in the case of wmd they put it
together and with the exception of the
state department intelligence one of 17
different intelligence agencies in the
United States with the exception of
state every single American intelligence
Community concluded it wasn't that it
was likely it wasn't that it was
probable They concluded Saddam had
stockpile as a biological and chemical
does that mean a hundred percent what is
conclude because I like what you said
there's a 60 80 chance there's X Y or Z
what number did they give CIO would
never put a number on it okay they're
smart enough bureaucrats not to do that
um but in the famous quote was when
Georgetown said to George Bush it's a
slam dunk that he has wmd
okay so now so so so slam dunk that he's
given that that's coming from a guy
George Tenet who was the director of CIA
since 96. 96 to 01 September that's five
years of experience being there you have
enough time to know who's on your team
who's capable who's not who you have to
fire who you have to keep it's not like
you don't have that experience to do
that right so uh I don't know all I
think about is like President Trump okay
a guy becomes a president you know how
something yesterday were debating to say
who's going to be on the Republicans the
Republican stage to debate right and
we're at this dinner everyone's kind of
throwing their names well let me tell
you you know we know obviously Trump's
going to be there well what do you think
about the Santas well I think he has to
do it because he's got a perfect resume
right now why wouldn't you do it you
know he's going to do it and uh the
other person I think that's going to be
there is from Georgia it's uh uh what's
his last name um Brian camp not Camp
it's a ratzenberger oh man it's another
name anyways I'll think about I'll say
the name the governor of Georgia people
are talking about him running for
president what's Ryan Cameron okay yeah
but then maybe I'm messing it up with
another name and then I said what about
zeldon so zeldon's not capable he's very
boring I said dude the guy lost by only
five percent in New York to hokel what
are you talking about yeah but he's
boring they're trying I said I know I
know they're trying to get him to become
the chairman of RNC but he's not running
to be there because he thinks he's going
to be president sometimes people run to
get a job like a lot of people run to
get a job on the administration of who
they think is going to win okay hey hey
you sit this one out I'm going to give
you this job hey you sit this one out
I'm going to give you this job and it's
a negotiation right kind of like that
day we all saw Elizabeth Warren Amy
Bernie everybody just sits it on hey
we're all getting behind Biden and
here's what you're going to be doing
fantastic we're all happy this kind of
worked out so
I I I'm convinced
um I'm convinced we were debating uh
James D Eugenio he wrote the book JFK
Revisited with Oliver Stone and he's
turned into a movie documentary all this
stuff
and I said the swamp killed JFK no well
yeah of course the swamp killed JFK the
swamp killed Lincoln no no it wasn't
Lincoln I said well you know it wasn't
swamped enough well you know all this
other stuff well he was kind of doing
stuff that his own party didn't like
civil rights all this what are you
talking about well yeah well the swamp
kind of went after Reagan but not not
necessarily well Reagan was kind of
trying well the SWAT went after swamp
one after Trump right yeah well well
then who is not part of the swamp in
politics today what are you talking
about who is not part of the swamp give
me names today that are not part of the
swamp that have roles inside they're
silent they can't say anything it's
McConnell swamp it's Biden swamp is
Obama swamp is you know Bush all these
names you're going through to be part of
the swamp so for me
um
some people want a job for resume some
people want it for a nicer profile on
Wikipedia Some People Want it because
they want to brag about it some people
wanted to make money
you don't know everyone's positive and
negative motives all I'm saying is when
when President Bush is picking his team
and you're bringing them inside if CIA
can't find that four fact if wmd was
right how does President Bush or not
just President Bush any other president
no four fact people you're bringing and
their motives are positive or negative
maybe some of these other guys the dick
cheneys of the world and Donald's
motives were negative maybe his is pure
but others are negative do you think
that responsibility lies on the person
that picked those people or no all right
let me get down to the Brass tax on this
do you think that George Tenet gave Bush
the advice or gave him the information
that he gave him at wmd because George
Tenet wanted to make money no I'm not
sometimes rum spelled and Dick Cheney
I'm talking about okay the thing about
tenet is he should have fire tenant I
don't keep a tenant why do you keep a
tenant his loyalty is not for you you
get rid of a tenant I I don't your dad
was working with the CIA your father
like if there's anybody I'm trying to
see who gave the advice to keep tenet
who was it your dad's got a lifelong
resume of all this stuff so maybe a part
of it for me is not even on W because
I'm convinced George would have W would
have called his father to say hey what
do we do with tenant and his father
probably gave him some kind of fatherly
advice and 10 of the influence is
probably from props it says okay let's
keep tenant why are you keeping tenant
all right I think George Bush would just
disagree with you on this one okay for
the exact reasons I said before you know
during the transition he interviews
tenet he likes tenant he thinks tenants
non-political and tenants knowledgeable
simple as that and it wasn't like he had
his guy no president wants to have his
guy at CIA what you want is an honest
broker at CIA who will tell you the
facts whether you like the facts or
don't like the fact slam dunk that's
it's a fact that's what he believed
because that's I mean this is what the
CIA concluded but to to say Ari you you
and I you're in oddsga if you like
sports it's all about odds we're in the
odds game it's a slam dunk you know like
when uh who was the one guy that said
Schiff Adam Schiff is it Adam Shifty the
interesting yeah you listen it's proven
we have a Intel listen Russian Russia oh
okay what are you talking about all
right so let's go back to intelligence
yeah president please intelligence so
look let's look at Iran today okay when
I look at the intelligence information
that's you know leaked into the news
when I see people say that Iran is six
months away three months away from
nuclear from having a nuclear weapon as
a result of their centrifuge uh Fusion
development systems
how does anybody know that three months
six months the intelligence is never
that precise
and so if you're the president and you
want to know do we have a threat from
Iran
how do you evaluate whether or not based
on what happened in Iraq
we have accurate information about Iran
it is so hard to make these judgments
and I don't think it's because the CIA
or Donald Rumsfeld or Dick Cheney or
anybody else's ulterior motives or
because they want to make money or they
want to do this or do that it's because
nations are really good at hiding their
secret stuff
and you think it's easy to penetrate
these nations you think it's easy for us
to put spies in places we I expect us to
be the best I I mean I brought the we're
probably the second best Mossad is the
best China is the best so I brought the
director of Assad a a former one uh uh
anyways I had them on we had a
conversation together and you know on
Intel that they got and who they trained
and how they trained and all this other
stuff
wouldn't we want to compete to be the
best so we can get this kind of Intel
that's why we are the greatest country
in the world how do you get a guy tenant
that no one talks about today slam dunk
are you kidding me like this cost how
many trillions of dollars that say that
we're paying because one guy said slam
dunk our taxes went up our debt went up
I I have a hard time with that so well
and lives were lost more importantly all
of that this goes back to the
fundamental question about Bush's Legacy
which you asked about and this is why I
said to you as somebody who I'm
reluctant to say it but I have to say it
is his legacy is going to invariably be
tied to the future of Iraq and to the
fact that we were wrong on wmd
are you worried that your legacy gets
caught up in that couldn't care less no
but I don't think that's I don't think
that's the uh and by the way I don't
think that's the question though my only
thing the question isn't tying this to
President Bush I'm not putting any of it
on him the only thing I'm putting on him
is why not bring somebody from that you
trust that you know in instead of a
tenant a track record shows this has
only happened twice
and the other guy that did it was a guy
named John F Kennedy and then you so
that gap of How It's been done for
however long is a long gap of 40 years
whatever the timeline is 37 years to to
do something like that so then the other
part the other part is
um a a person like a trump gets in okay
when a person like a trump gets in to
put a team together
my biggest concern was who he's going to
pick
and the reason why my biggest concern
was who he's going to pick is
who do you who do you trust to to put in
there that actually has the Rel do you
only bring Outsiders I mean he still did
a great job with his policies
but you're you're going up against
people that have been doing favors for
each other for years and you're coming
and you want to put a team who is on
your side
two would be on your site like who do
you pick do you go and pick people that
were former bush people do you go and
pick former Reagan people that's a long
time ago do you go after George Will
George doesn't like you do you go and
put you know and then the people that
you bring in
what are their motives so when when
people talk about the motives of wmd and
money being made again this goes to uh
uh a Dick Cheney Rumsfeld some of these
guys where they are and what their
motives were to make money because
obviously money was made when you see
what their background was with
Halliburton all these other things that
they were sitting on so let me ask this
question from you what are your thoughts
on Lincoln project and what they're
doing
hold on I need to go back and clarify
something because when I said you asked
me about my personal Legacy and I said I
could care less I want to make sure it
doesn't bother me what the critics say I
faithfully and accurately reported to
the American people the information that
the White House had and so I I know what
I said and why I said it it was because
it was provided to me as accurate
information so I stated it as such
um I don't want anybody to think when I
say I don't care I don't care about the
consequences or the loss of lives Etc I
want to make sure people don't
misinterpret that I also so
believe that you do care about your
legacy in general though know yourself
personally look my job was to be the
president's spokesman
well I reported to the president and
it's what he thinks about it's what he
cared about I'm not even realizing I
love it I'm just saying like your legacy
it does matter to you though no you know
you build your legacy over different
years I'm very proud of everything I did
in the government including at the White
House I'm proud of the communications
company I've built I love what I do and
so I have fun and it's it's my bosses
and my clients that I care about I
really am not the type that really
worries about image name what do people
say how many Twitter followers do you
have that's never been what I take my
motivation from and I never will I know
Pat once asked this question about
Lincoln project yeah I saw that speech
you gave uh at the Reagan Library
it's like an hour speech I want to say
maybe how long ago was that by the way
well I've done a several there was this
when my book just came out yes okay okay
now that was uh July there's a lot of
questions I can ask you with that but
I'll be very specific on this one you
said that if you get into politics and
if you truly believe in what you're
doing and if you follow your heart your
passion you truly believe whether you're
Republican Democrat libertarian whatever
there's no more fulfilling job in the
world yep why do you say that
because there's only one industry for
beliefs
other than religion and that's
government
I mean how exciting is it how
influential how powerful can it be to
make decisions that can move worlds move
the nation change people's lives you
know we were talking a little bit about
Iran
I am so
focused on the future of Iran and that
Nation with so many young people and if
the United States can use its power and
its leverage to bring about change in
Iran and throw out a theocracy that has
been suppressing tens of millions of
Persian people who are so Western
oriented to begin with what a powerful
peaceful change that'd be in the Middle
East you can't do that from Wall Street
you you can't do that from any corner of
the or you do it in government
government is where you can so many make
so many changes in life not only in that
and in social issues and economic issues
and and examples that you set for
children about what's right or what's
wrong
and that's why I encourage young people
despite the polarization of today if you
believe if you think global warming is
going to melt the Earth in 12 years then
get your butt to Washington and do
something about it if you think that
taxes need to be cut that capitalism
needs to have an injection of something
to make a throt get down to Washington
and pass laws
this is what is exciting yeah now not
everybody's like that many people want
to go into different careers many people
find the government be full of BS fine
don't go but for those who want to make
a difference government's a fantastic
deal do you think it'd be better how do
I position this question is it better
for young people to get a real life real
job first and then get into politics
it's a mix or get into politics first
and then after you get into politics
then you're going to end up in the
lobbying world and all that and that has
a lot of gray areas there so is there a
better recipe for people first you know
for my example I went right from college
by accident into politics I I moved home
to play baseball and then I got a job as
a press secretary for a New York state
assemblyman who ran for Congress and he
lost but I got the bug so I stayed in
politics for 21 years and then I left
Washington I never wanted to be a
lobbyist and I have no political clients
I built a private sector company mostly
in sports
everybody has a different path but the
way you can have Washington be the most
effective for the American people as
have people who reflect America that
means yes have a bunch of people who
worked in business and then go to
Washington a bunch of people who worked
in non-profits and go to Washington a
bunch of people have a religious
background and then go to Washington and
have people who go to Washington right
away as young people who are young and
idealistic and believe it's a mix
because America is a mix so there's no
one formula you want something that
looks like the country I think what
you're saying is not so much diversity
but diversity of thought yes diversity
of opinions I'm a big believer in the
latter and not the former not diversity
for diversity I think what what Adam's
trying to say are he's running for mayor
and for the non-retirement I mean like
non-retirement to everybody here but
it's okay let's go back to the wonderful
question of what do you think about
Lincoln project I I think they're a
bunch of charlatans who are making money
you really believe that yeah
tell us how you really feel a little bit
but I can hold it back a little bit even
like look you've just met McCain's
campaign manager he's at the head of the
sure that tip of the spear sure I mean
Steve has had a transformation he worked
for George Bush too he no longer is a
republican he can't stand Republicans
he's responsible for Sarah Palin in many
ways and he's always lived to regret
that
um so I think he's doing Penance
um
look that you know their beliefs are
genuine in that they can't stand Trump
and they want to build something to
fought Trump but now they have built
something to fight Republicans but the
organization itself was corrupt it had
terrible internal problems personal
problems
embarrassing problems what like what
just Financial are you serious I want I
want to hear about it well one of their
Founders had real serious issues with
his personal behavior in his personal
life and the way he treated employees
were his subordinates
you don't know about Conway who are you
talking about no no you don't know about
this Rick Wilson well I'm not gonna look
it's all public I I really don't follow
Lincoln project for a living but they've
had a series of embarrassing issues and
issues involving real financial problems
in their own organization
um I'm all for groups being contrarian
and for Democrats who take on Democrats
Republicans take on Republicans it's
part of our mix I just don't like that
one group
and so I bring the subs okay so maybe
let me ask a different question what do
you think about Liz Cheney
I like Liz ideologically for being a
conservative I have no problems with her
vote on impeachment that's what she
believed in that's what she did I do
have problems with her serving on the
911 Commission as 9 11 committee because
Nancy Pelosi asked her to do it as soon
as Nancy Pelosi rejected Kevin
McCarthy's Republican selections for the
committee no Republican should have
joined that committee no you're saying
911 the January 6th commission I'm sorry
January 6th okay sorry you said 9 11.
yeah I'm sorry the January 6th committee
got it
um so again it to me it's principled if
you want to vote to impeach Donald Trump
vote to impeach Donald Trump that's a
principled position and then deal with
your constituents
but serving on that committee
Congress cannot work
if Republicans can't appoint Republicans
to committees and Democrats can't
appoint Democrats if all of it has to be
done at the behest of the speaker
then there is no opposition party
everything is controlled by the speaker
she should not have let herself get put
in that position so she's fighting a
personal Vendetta against President
Trump which I understand
but I think she went too far so the
reason why I brought up Lincoln project
is
we saw how they went after Trump the
videos they make and it's constant no
problem and by the way be a good credit
to them I think they influenced the 2020
election a little bit I think they had
uh some influence I don't know what
percentage I don't know what number they
definitely had that information on what
they did okay they were very good
marketers what they made what they did
the part that's confusing to me is they
said they stood for conservative beliefs
now they're going after the scientists
you know did you see the the they go
after all Republicans now yeah they are
not conservative who's funding Lincoln
project by the way
I don't know they were able to raise a
tremendous amount of Grassroots money a
tremendous amount of money from
Democrats who viewed it as a bunch of
Republicans McCain people going after
Trump so Democrats like that contrarian
play and boy were they well funded
yeah I'm trying to see if the the
similar names are behind the Lincoln
project raised a whopping 39 million
dollars from July through September
helping Fuel anti-trump and Blitz
uh yeah I'm curious to know who's
funding these guys is it is it uh there
was a guy in Ohio him and I would always
debate and he would say but Patrick you
don't understand I'm a republican but
Patrick you know I'm like listen I'm an
independent myself I'm pro-capitalism
I'm fiscally conservative
I'm about to leave me alone freedom I
have some libertarian Tendencies some
independent Tendencies and cons fiscally
um would you would consider me a
republican fiscally because I want to be
left alone uh economically let me do my
part I'll pay my taxes I'll do my part
but Pat I'm a republican but Pat I'm a
Republican and he that's how he conv
convince people to kind of flip so one
day I say uh Carl
you can fool a lot of people
but you can't fool me man your strategy
on how you're doing it you're full of
[ __ ] is what you're doing I say I
understand the power of what you're
doing because people are listening to
you saying well let me tell you as a
republican I'm embarrassed on my party
I'm embarrassing my party it's a very
very good tactic and strategy okay
because guess what CNN wants to put on
all the time anybody that says I'm a
Republican and I'm embarrassed of my
party so you got what's his name
denzinger uh Adam kensinger and some of
these guys are like oh I'm embarrassing
all of these guys Joe Walsh our friend
yeah we had Joe Walsh here it was a very
friendly uh time that we had him on the
podcast but are they at this point like
non they're so irrelevant that no one's
following because they're still getting
some traction on Twitter when I see them
are they irrelevant are they not going
to have any impact are they still
effective I think for those who are in
the business who pay attention and know
about the Lincoln Project's problems and
issues they're irrelevant
um but if you've got enough tens of
millions of dollars and you can put
advertisements on the air people can
watch and that has influence but I'll
caution you
our system is so big so you spent 10
million dollars on a campaign
other people spend hundreds of millions
of dollars
the president was insane 100 million
dollars in like a month I've just seen
so many examples of people using money
thinking they can solve a problem and
the American people say ah I could care
less about your money on voting my way
so money is a piece of politics but
principles and ideas are much more
important
Lincoln project is one of many people
who have their ore in the water spending
money
I have a question regarding Lincoln
project because it's fascinating we've
talked about it a million times Pat
especially during 2020 but this what do
you think life is like in the Conway
household ah you got George Conway wanna
you know uh uh constitutional lawyer I
want to say one of the founders of the
Lincoln's project and then you have his
wife kellyanne Conway as unabashed you
know Trump supporter as it gets some may
say that she's the reason he got elected
in 2016 because she stood up to the
press the daughter is making Tick Tock
videos saying how much he hates the mom
and they I don't even know if they have
the other kids but that household means
must be so combustible you know they say
like what's harder to to to be married
to whether you're in her faith inner
politically you know in a religion you
know black and white you know intermixed
interracial but inner politics
especially these days it's so divisive
that household has to be insane how do
you interpret all that yeah I'm
reluctant to put myself inside anybody's
relationship
um you don't know all the facts I will
say this when I worked at the White
House and for anybody who works in the
white house I don't care what your party
is when you leave that difficult place
where there's a lot of burdens put on
you
you should be able to come home to a
loving family who supports you
and if they don't support your politics
or your boss's politics they should have
enough love and respect for you
to keep their mouth shut publicly
but that's not what they're doing though
that's all I'll say yeah that's what
anybody should do and I I 100 agree with
what you're saying
um but fully go ahead but what I mean
I'm just thinking of you okay you're
you're you're out there you're a known
person you're a public figure you've got
money you've got okay so imagine Jen who
is fully supportive of you it's the most
supportive loyal loving wife it's
amazing what they have imagine of you
doing your thing and you come home to
Jen
and she's literally talking trash about
you and your boss every single day and
you've got kids and you're sitting down
at the dinner table that's got to be so
uncomfortable as a husband as a wife yes
I would never be married to to to that
person just wouldn't work out because I
asked 101 questions to ask before you
get engaged I'm being dead serious on
our second date please have my back I'm
not I'm not playing that game I'm I'm
not going to tolerate that game at all
in our household now having said that
you can manage that with your marriage
but you don't have that conversation
when the kid is born and saying hey you
best have my back or else I'm not
bringing you to the world the kids like
who the hell are you of course you chose
to you know you guys chose the procreate
I'm gonna be whatever way I want to be
Ronald Reagan's son is not a supporter
of Ronald Reagan you know his biological
son not Michael Reagan so how do you do
that was your bad father or did they do
a bad job did kids have a mind of their
own so I'm less on the kid and more on
the spouse I think that's a problem yeah
of course the kid is the kid you're
embarrassed about it you feel bad for
them uh and I don't even like to watch
those clips and say oh did you see they
can't have their household it's a little
bit uh uh there's a million stories of
you know kids fighting with their
parents I mean we can go on for days
years about that but husband and wives
on air politically like saying exact
opposite messaging yeah that's un
unheard of that's what I'm saying Kelly
and Conway
is one of the goats
of her job
what that woman did
I don't know of anybody is as good as
she is in what she did not many people
she's on the list of the best at what
she did with her job if there's no Kelly
and Conway Trump doesn't win 2016. I
agree with she's that much of a beast I
don't know if you agree with me or not
or you disagree but I think she's
amazing at what she does no I think Gene
provided president Trump candidate Trump
an invaluable service I think she was
one of the calmer cooler heads at the
White House in the early years when she
was there
um you know she's not part of the
president's re-election in 2024 here
um she's more a free agent now and an
analyst on Fox News
I told her I said If You're Gonna if
this is gonna happen again you gotta be
here her now we're talking about this a
few months ago at uh an event but
anyways that's a different story so you
know I want to ask you about somebody
who has a reputation of being a
sweetheart that people love this guy
uh uh just a very kind loving
personality what are your thoughts on
Dick Cheney
[Laughter]
I liked vice president Cheney
um he was a curmudgeon a tough guy
um
but you know what people don't
understand about my job at the White
House is I worked for President Bush I
was Bush's spokesman and Bush was the
boss
Jenny was a vice president The Outsiders
thought Cheney's in control training is
in charge which Bush always could care
less about because again the guy's a
confident guy with thick skin and that
criticism was so wrong that it never
bothered Bush so I looked at the vice
president as one of many good advisors
that bush had whispering in his ear
sometimes he was a little too truculent
um you know I think with the CIA what
does truculent mean across Layman's uh
a little too uh tough argumentative
curmudgeon
um
personalities professionally is a little
truculent
um but he did it because he believed had
nothing to do with money and nothing to
do with Halliburton it was because he
believed you don't believe that you
don't believe in either money no fully
no first of all he severed his ties to
Halliburton so literally how could he
make a profit off of anything that he
did because Halliburton did severed ties
he was no longer with them
um so whatever money Halliburton made or
lost was immature real to the vice
president
umholder
I think he had to divest I'm sure
everybody I'm sure presidents and vice
presidents I think are not allowed to
have any stock or mutual funds
um
but presidents are not allowed to have
yeah I think they all divest or it's
blind Trust
it's probably manage probably about a
trust yeah it's a blind trust
um but anyway to the point he was an
audio log and and a very big believer in
the old neocon muscular foreign policy
and that he was very much on the side to
get rid of Saddam
um but the CIA would tell you is if
there was any interference they ever got
from the White House it was not from
President Bush not from President Bush's
people it was the vice president and the
vice president's people who put pressure
on the CIA to conclude that there were
ties between Saddam and Al Qaeda
that's an angle that the vice president
particularly thought was true and he
really wanted the CIA to run that down
President Bush and see I would tell you
this always said to the CIA just tell me
what you know
and he gave him no pressure one way or
another he said just tell me what you
know Ari for every 10 times you spoke to
President Bush how many times did you
talk to Dick Cheney
well Cheney would be in a lot of the
meetings so Cheney would be sitting
there but as anybody from the White
House will tell you Cheney didn't talk
much
Bush did the talking Bush's advisors did
the talking and then Cheney would get
together with bush once a week for their
private lunch and that's when Cheney
would say to Bush here's what I think
that was the vice president's
opportunity then to influence the
president which he did
but in the meetings in all these
different meetings
Cheney didn't talk much did did I guess
what was their relationship meaning
Cheney's how many years older than
George W bush yeah but that didn't
matter dozen 20 years so it's got I mean
well a little bit maybe like why maybe
seniority wisdom I I kind of that means
Joe Biden knows more than anybody else
well yeah that's a whole nother
conversation but
the knock on Cheney was that he was this
evil doer running the show would you
agree to that at least the knock on it
yeah oh and I dealt with that all the
time before 9 11 especially I mean the
knock on the Bush Administration was
Cheney's in charge right it was always
nonsense what complete nonsense right
there there's there's the reality then
there's Optics yeah like but the press
it always has to have something to chew
on and so that's what they chewed on
which was a meaningless thing to chew on
got it but you did say that he was the
one that kind of wanted the CIA to chase
down the the story about Al Qaeda yeah I
think the CIA would tell you that so
what does that mean exactly he kind of
wanted to invade Iraq oh is that what
that means Cheney definitely wanted to
depose Saddam oh he thought it would
promote world peace and would be in
America's interest it wasn't Cheney's
decision though it was Bush's decision
and how how much part of
how much a part of Bush's decision
was influenced by the fact that his
father went to war in Iraq zero uh
Desert Storm Schwarzkopf and he didn't
get the job done quote unquote
you don't think that played a little
part of of going out put yourself in
George Bush's shoes
America is going to attack September
11th takes place yeah CIA says on
September 11th after the attack it's not
a question of if it's a question of when
there will be a second wave there will
be a second wave
and that starts to create all the
infrastructure and the decisions that
bush starts to make about how to fortify
America and never let us be hit again
which is entire mentality as we got hit
once
I will never let this country be hit
again
Saddam has zero nothing to do with
September 11th and I said that
repeatedly from the podium right that's
why we invaded Afghanistan not Iraq
first correct but again put yourself in
Bush's shoes so Saddam had nothing to do
with 9 11.
but you are told there will be a second
wave and then you're told Saddam
definitely has wmd
and Bush's my mindset is I will never
let this country be attacked again so
you can decide all right he's got
biological and chemical weapons and
there's nothing America can do about it
we'll just have to hope he never uses
them or
I believe in the doctrine of preemption
I'm going to take Saddam out because he
is wmd
and that is the decision that George
Bush ultimately made that people argue
about for decades now whether it was
right or wrong and I repeatedly as I
said now it was based on false premises
that he had wmd when he did not got it
have you read this position sure have
you read it Adam I'm not sure I'm not
familiar the book that uh President Bush
wrote no I have not okay he talks about
that I think in the last chapter or
second to the last chapter
piece of beef it's actually a very good
book to read straight up it's a very
good book to read if you haven't read it
or listened to audible it's a very very
good book to read
he says you know exactly what he's
saying here did the president ever have
any um
did the conversation about nuclear
attack come up or no nuclear towards
them or no it came out once in the fact
that Dick Cheney went on I believe it
was uh NBC uh Meet the Press and he went
too far and he said something along the
lines that Saddam is developing or has
developed nuclear capacities when when
he didn't
um we did not have intelligence saying
that Saddam had developed nuclear he had
biological and chemical
um
and then you had to draw that back
because the vice president went too far
um but it was inside the administration
we had enough to worry about biological
and chemical if that was the conclusion
we didn't have to worry about him having
nuclear now one of the pieces that Colin
Powell used at the United Nations turned
out also to be false information
that Saddam had sent uh had had some I
think was centrifuges some metal tubes
that were used for nuclear development
which caused alarm bells to go off but
we never concluded or CIA never
concluded that Saddam had a nuclear
we never can no I guess my question is
more different like okay so if you go
back and you look at uh what do you
think is a bigger bigger attack
uh you know you look at the bigger event
you think Pearl Harbor or 911.
I don't compare
I learned from a smart man once who
lost two of his three children that you
don't compare tragedies
uh but you would say both are pretty big
you know tragic events that happen top
you know in the top events that happen
the history of America fair enough
absolutely okay do you think it was a
right move on us to uh I know FDR didn't
do it but Lyndon Johnson not Johnson
Truman ended up uh deciding to Nuke
Japan you think that was the right move
on us yes you think it was yes okay
uh saved a million American lives
so that was the right move for us to
make when at what point do you think it
would be a right move to do that again
as some if somebody does that to your
country
what a great question you know the world
has changed since World War II where
everything was a gigantic land Army Navy
known troop movements we're in a more
stealthy world now of terrorism
you know I don't think the right
response if a terrorist detonated a
dirty bomb in New York City this
afternoon
who are you supposed to Nuke
there's no one to Nuke
you have to do it through Special Forces
you have to do it through these behind
the scenes clandestine operations
if Russia Today launched a series of
ICBM missiles at the United States would
we have to respond in kind yes because
we know who it is to source and because
if you ever say no we won't then you're
inviting the attack if you want the
turns to work you better mean it so do
do you think like right now
you know hey all I'm asking for is for
NATO to back off of Ukraine and stop
inviting them NATO is opening the doors
for Ukraine to join NATO
and that's a way of NATO saying yeah
Putin we thought you were strong you're
really not if a small little place like
Ukraine is able to hang with you yeah
and you haven't done anything yet yeah
we are letting Ukraine considering them
joining NATO what do you have to say
about that so then he goes and sits
there as a man running a country called
Russia with a rich history of animosity
towards one country in the world which
is America because philosophically we're
on complete opposite ends at least at
one point before Ronald Reagan comes up
and says Tear Down the Wall etc etc
Gorbachev okay great
do you think Putin's at a point where
it's a turning point where he's got to
make a decision you think he's sitting
there or no he's not there and he's
gonna just sit there and negotiate and
figure out a way to do this and lose
this and allow Ukraine to join NATO I
cannot put myself in Putin's head
I was hoping you could do that yeah
I don't know what his calculations are
what his breaking point is I think it's
amazing the resistance of the ukrainians
I heard Mike Pompeo the former Secretary
of State say the other day that it
doesn't surprise him that Russia hasn't
been able to pull this off he said their
ability the ability of Any Nation to
move hundreds of thousands of forces and
have supply chain and vehicles that work
he said that's a daunting task it's all
it's so hard to pull off that he said it
doesn't surprise me Russia couldn't do
it
um I think Russia is now being seen for
what it is which is absolute overrated
military power they still have nuclear
weapons so so as long as those nuclear
weapons can fly there's a danger and we
have to take it seriously but
the ability to pull off a significant
land invasion
is really really hard unless you drill
all the time train all the time prep all
the time which the United States does
we're one of the few who can do it
um Russia's Hollow you know what uh uh
by the way would you agree that most
people thought Russia would have
destroyed Ukraine yes most people were
not like if it's like a football game
like oh they're going to crush him and
then oh my God what the hell happened
here this was not supposed to you know
Patriots were supposed to beat the
Giants but they came back this is very
weird is it really Ukraine though or did
they kind of to use your sports
technology they've got a couple
All-Stars on the sidelines that you're
helping them out right it's like a last
minute guy you pull in but I guess okay
so shamatya the days talking to uh uh uh
Lex I think he's talking to Lex he's on
his podcast and the conversation was
about uh America with the interest rates
and what we're doing and Powell and
increasing the rates we can't afford a
war right now because you know money is
so expensive for us right now that we
couldn't finance a war right now you
know where us we're not ready for some
like that how much of that is true like
do you think if something did happen in
America neither the finance a war it
wouldn't be you know they would still do
it and versus how much you think rates
and a person like Powell you know he
called them the most powerful man in the
world because him increasing the rate is
preventing America from being on Attack
Mode where you have to kind of take the
step back do you agree with them War
should never ever be about whether we
can or cannot afford it War should only
be about do we have no choice but to
fight it
and if you have no choice but to fight
it then you're gonna fund it
so you just have to get the sequence
right and and it has nothing to do with
money
um
but you know to Donald Trump's credit
Trump's right when he says he was the
one president of the recent note who's
kept us out of wars he ended Wars you
know he gets the credit for destroying
Isis uh other leaders in the Middle East
sharing that credit as well but Trump
stepped up and empowered the military
and sent the signal to the Arab Middle
East fight these suckers take them out
I'm going to have your back as opposed
to President Obama who says you know I
don't we can't attack them
and Trump got it right and then Trump
did keep us out of wars and I also
believe that with the withdrawal from
Afghanistan if Trump were president
Taliban would not have gotten away with
what they did and Kaaba will not have
fallen I think Trump's conditions based
withdrawal was valid and I think the
Taliban was scared to death of Donald
Trump because he's irrational people
don't know what moves he's going to make
next he took out solimani in Iran and so
people thought don't mess with Trump
nobody thought that about Biden
you don't find Biden intimidating the
most popular president of all time 81
million votes you and that's like a
Guinness Book of World Record but going
back to Trump so
um
questions about obviously Trump
announces he's running for office okay
you know yesterday hey they're going
after his taxes and they're going to get
this and they're going to get that and
they're you know trying to figure out a
different way to eliminate him from
running
during dinner last night if these are
all successful business folks and and
everybody's has different opinion well
you know I hope they are able to get
them on taxes because if they do he
can't run I don't want him to run and
well they send if he wins he wins you
gotta let him run but he's like no he's
the worst thing that ever happened well
he had a economy was good when he was
doing this well it's not fair what they
did to him no he deserved everything
he's the shadiest he's the line so it's
you're watching everybody on where
they're at this is what they're saying
at dinner last night it was so
interesting it was and and they were
open about it like the way they were
talking like these are people you know
some of these names yeah these are names
no major names yeah I'm not mostly
Republican uh no not at all well of
course it's a Democrats 100 Wall Street
types it was Republicans there was there
was there were nobody was independent
everybody was left or right is what they
were okay it was very across the which
was great it made dinner exciting
because there was a little bit of a back
and forth so we know Trump is running
are you on the mindset that the Santas
for sure is going to be running
nothing's for sure in this business
right but it sure seems like he is and I
hope he does you think anybody else will
run or is there anybody you'd like to
see around there'll be a there'll be a
small bunch of them nowhere near like 16
when we had 17 candidates or something
like that but I think there's going to
be eight or nine at least at the
beginning
um I think a couple of them are going to
be just Chris Christie and Larry Hogan I
I think the governor former governor of
New Jersey and the current governor of
Maryland
um I don't think they have a chance
you've got to be a real conservative
populist candidate to be successful in
today's Republican party but I think
there'll be a small smattering the issue
for Trump is if it's one or two who are
conservative populist Outsider
candidates running against them he could
lose
if it's three four or five they split
the vote and Trump wins
who's your Dark Horse meaning everyone's
talking about Trump DeSantis you know
even Mike Pence shows up and you didn't
give any uh validity
pompeo's thinking about it Nikki Haley
is thinking about it
um wouldn't surprise me if there's some
other governor who comes out of the
woodwork who's kind of laying low now
who moves in later
um
but you know DeSantis is the flavor of
the month legitimately so I think he's a
great decision maker I love the way he
just confronts big things and makes
fundamental decisions
I think his vulnerability especially in
Iowa and New Hampshire is going to be
he's not a retail politician
he's not an enjoyable laughable
backslapping kind of pile and in New
Hampshire that's really important Iowa
to some extent because those are the
initial primaries and caucuses to hang
in the Republican party right correct
those are the first two and as they say
in New Hampshire uh somebody asked who
are you supporting and the resident of
New Hampshire said how should I know
I've only met the candidate three times
um they take it seriously as retail
politics there and most candidates camp
out when you say retail Politics the old
hey you're shaking hands kissing babies
hey hey I'm a beer with that guy
spending time in meetings in people's
living rooms yeah not everything's a
giant Ballroom not everything is a rally
in New Hampshire they want that local
touch to say that's not the census's
strength so look what I love about where
we are today and I'm open-minded on
Donald Trump there's a lot about Donald
Trump I objective especially in terms of
his personality there's a lot I admire
about his policies
um but my position personally and as a
Fox News analyst is I like being a
consumer make these guys compete and
then me as a consumer I'll tell you what
I'm going to do at the end of the day I
want to watch it see how it plays out
and decide who's the strongest and who's
the best
um you know I think the issue for Donald
Trump is is he made himself too hot to
handle has he just made everybody start
to realize people realized it before but
now say it publicly that
do we really need all these
controversies do we need all the baggage
that comes with what Donald Trump does
and the way he does it yes he was great
on the economy yes he was great on
foreign policy yes he was great for
achieving peace in the Middle East yes
he was great for Israel a lot of issues
which are important to me
but the question is
has he made himself so hot to handle
that none of that matters
can we have somebody who's equally good
as a decision maker equally good on
policy who just doesn't go too far
and can actually attract Independents
and Democrats that's what I want to see
play out in the primary
so your your uh you're not sure yet do
you think both of them have a chance of
winning the whole thing like if if uh he
becomes Trump becomes a pro Republican
nominee or DeSantis become Republican
nominee do you think both of them have a
chance of winning the whole thing at
this early stage I would say somebody
other than Trump has a better shot at
winning the whole thing
because Democrats and independents just
I see a very difficult Road getting them
to support Donald Trump and one of the
biggest factors in the upcoming primary
is going to be if all the polls start to
show let's just say DeSantis DeSantis is
beating Biden scientists is beating
Harris by five points and Trump is only
beating them by one
that is going to be a shocking message
to Republican primary voters who say I'm
not taking a chance I do not want
somebody who could lose this thing so
keep your eye on those head-to-head
polls as they start to emerge in early
2023 you still trust polls
you just said a month ago 238 seats and
we're going to win Senate and we're
going to have the house and it's going
to be a red wave and and first of all
you ain't the only one I think 99 of
people everybody got it wrong on what it
was
uh you think it was really the Roe v way
that was the biggest driver what what do
you think was the biggest driver last
minute two one is the reason that a
party gets his clock cleaned in its
first midterm election it's a referendum
on the current president right in 2022
it was a referendum on Joe Trump
it was a referendum on two presidents
if it had only been a referendum on Joe
Biden Republicans would have had the 25
30 seats in the House of cap control of
the Senate but Donald Trump never left
the stage he still hovered so
independent voters especially instead of
breaking overwhelmingly against Joe
Biden they went split right down the
middle Democrats carried him by two
percentage points
that was the biggest factor of all then
Roe v Wade did play a role into it as
well that helped motivate a lot of
democrat turnout don't you think the
whole we got to save democracy these
election deniers like we had like that
don't you think that was also a major
factor but that ties into the whole
Trump stand on the field
um that was a factor that motivated High
Democrat turnout and the turnout in the
midterm was quite High typically there's
a massive drop-off between a
presidential year and a midterm this
drop-off was was not near as high or as
much as a historical Dropout but isn't
that all because since 2016
every election has been record turnout
because whether you like them or not
Trump trump made you pay attention to
politics yes you know Obama whether you
like them or not like yeah okay cool guy
whatever he didn't like it wasn't
must-see TV Trump must see TV I don't
know if you know that or not massive
um but he
the
what I will give him credit for is
you know he woke a lot of people up
whether you like him or you know don't
like them support them or do not support
him this record turnout is all due to
him for the last eight years right I
agree
well I agree I mean 16 broke all the
records and then 20 broke all the
records and now 22 for for midterms what
do you think 28 18 at a higher turnout
than 22. okay but that was the first
year of trump midterm well he got
crushed it was it's about the midterms
and this is why this whole notion of
democracy is in trouble our democracy is
freaking thriving that's why people are
turning out so much whether you love
Trump or you hate Trump or democracy
functions it works yeah you know I could
make the case that there's a reason for
low turnouts because people are happy
when things are good and calm you don't
have to turn out all of a sudden people
see a threat to America Donald Trump or
I love Donald Trump so we have massive
turnout that's a healthy thriving
democracy and what settled it the will
of the people
that's what makes a democracy work
uh let me let me ask a different
question here let's change it up a
little bit uh
you know how sometimes you like you
watch certain people and you're like you
know I wish this guy would have done XYZ
I wish this guy would have ran a
business I wish that guy would have ran
up I wish this guy would have ran is
there anybody that you looked at he said
this guy I I wish he would have ran for
president he would have made one hell of
a president is there anybody that you've
said that to or you've thought about
because this is the industry you've been
a part of yeah I mean I've occasionally
had thoughts about that with Peyton
Manning
until he declares this candidacy and
then the Press will tear them up are you
are you being serious you know I do
think about Outsiders I do that's what
I'm asking I think that's why I've
always been open-minded about Donald
Trump despite the fact that I work for
establishment yeah figures I've always
just looked at things much bigger
um
but the problem is as soon as you're in
New England as soon as you enter the New
England vote Republicans don't get it
anyway oh as soon as you enter The Fray
as soon as you enter the campaign you
get torn up so who's got the ability
who's got the thick sand to handle that
and most athletes don't you know it's
it's really hard look at Herschel Walker
in Georgia
um he could still win though yeah it's
tough he could still win that's that's
going to be a tough race but you also
hear like the names like Tom Hanks and
The Rock and Oprah Michelle Obama yeah
and part of it's the info infotainment
side of politics
um you know I do like to think about
that but like I said again as soon as
you enter the ring boy you're gonna find
out what you got and you're gonna find
out if you have thin skin or thick skin
anybody else that's automatic like
anybody for you to say that this guy's
got thick skin he could do it because
it's funny how you you took it as it's
not just communication it's not just
witty it's not just being you know funny
or even having good policies you have to
have thick skin who is there that you'd
say this guy this guy can manage all of
it is there anyone yeah
there's nobody I would put my finger on
right now okay I think what I love about
American politics is somebody emerges
Off the Bench and becomes a star
and we don't know who that is yeah and
we're not supposed to we don't need to
know who the big name of 2023 is yet
it's up to them to prove it to the
American people and so when I hear the
Democrats say they have no bench after
Biden I always come that's bull you got
a deep bench it's just that nobody knows
their names yet they will emerge you
same thing for the Republicans you think
newsom's running
he says he's not now he said he's not
yeah yeah you can't believe it I think
there's a silver lining for republicans
and the fact that we underperformed in
2022 and that's if Republicans have
taken the house by big numbers taken the
Senate Democrats would have risen up and
said to Biden we are not placing our
future in the 82 year old guy as our
nation goes into recession who's really
unpopular and just lost the House and
Senate so now the Democrats are going to
get stuck with Joe Biden they're going
to have an 82 year old nominee in 2024.
and I think that's a huge opportunity
for whoever the Republican candidate is
to clean the guy's clock because I just
don't see the American people going for
82 to 86 year old second term president
now either do I to follow up on Pat's
question just because you've been around
presidents uh obviously George W bush uh
the historian John Meacham you familiar
with him they I think they believe I
believe they asked him well if there's
one characteristic that a president can
have above all what would it be that
makes him a good president and I believe
his answer was measured got to be
measured right almost like stoicism okay
you know Pat referenced being
charismatic and being energetic and you
know you talked about you know uh living
room politics what was the term you used
uh
you know when you can like what you're
doing New Hampshire would you call it oh
retail retail politics I was thinking
what words there's a lot of words that
we're trying to Define over here I'm
Googling a lot of things but if you
could give your assessment if there was
one word that would make a good
president you said you know
not thin skin like all these words we're
using what what word would you use moral
a lot happens from moral strength and
moral Authority that's how you inspire
people people think you're a good person
doing things for good reasons they will
follow you they'll disagree with you on
some issues but they'll say he knows
more than I do
I hope he turns out right if people
think you're immoral if you do things
for wrong reasons you can never get that
back so moral measured I like that but
measured's internal measured is what you
do when you've got the CIA telling you
one thing and you've got somebody else
telling you another or you've got one
expert saying
2008 market crash that you've got to
intervene and another expert saying to
you don't intervene whatever you do let
this figure self out
that's where president has to be
measured listen to both sides ask good
questions and come up with an answer but
measured is not how you sell policies
you sell policy through Charisma and a
compelling approach
can I give you a little bit of pushback
yeah yeah you know sort of the the the
dichotomy between Trump versus Biden was
that moral
argument well you know Biden's a nice
guy you know he's at least he's a good
guy he's not he's not Trump who's this
evil character he's a good guy you know
that whole thing so maybe that was the
moral versus immoral I don't think I
don't think I think people made a
judgment about Trump's morality I don't
think Joe Biden inspired people on the
basis of morality I think that for some
people particularly the media who fell
for it they just thought Biden was a
good guy you know that kind of that's
what I'm saying exactly but that's not
moral that's that's a different measure
um you know I'm not sure about Biden's
morality I think there's a lot we don't
know because I do think he lied about
what he knew about his son's business
dealings a whole series of texts and
emails and photos have come out the show
Joe Biden lied about that he's been
contradicted by evidence
um so I I and you know when I see Joe
Biden saying about Mitt Romney that Mitt
Romney and Republicans want to put you
all back in Chains as he said to a black
audience in 2012. I do question Joe
Biden's morality Joe Biden has a history
of playing on America's racial divisions
Jim Crow 2.0 put you all back in Chains
semi-fascists Joe Biden loves to play in
that arena for the purpose of dividing
American people and drawing support to
the Democratic party but when he says
that Mitt Romney and Republicans want to
return this country to slavery you're
going to tell me that's a moral
statement that's a moral man that's a
man playing some of the lowest politics
around racial lines
identity politics vicious game
thank you for that response what's this
what's this right here 2018 son I love
you more than you'll ever know but you
got to get your things together you need
help
uh Joe Biden voice Montana Brighton is a
wonderful go a little lower Gola lore go
a little lower
uh in a message the former president
stat I call to tell you I love you I
love you more than the whole world pal
you got to get some help I know you
don't know what to do I don't either
well that that's yeah that's not the
real one no the one I was looking for is
the one where he says hey man uh I think
you're clear right the New York exactly
the times is releasing the piece I think
you're clear you know etc etc what do
you think about what the musk is about
to do here with all the stuff is
releasing with Twitter you know I love
it
um on the other hand who cares about
Twitter and why are we all so hung up on
this stuff you know if Twitter went away
I'd be fine I like Twitter I tweet
that's a great way to get your message
out Etc but life is bigger than that and
that's all always uh oh I reflection I
think you just poked the bear a little
bit Pat is very big on Twitter right now
oh no no I I'm I'm curious to know what
he thinks about it you know for me uh my
my thought is for a guy to buy Twitter
that is officially not running it the
same way that YouTube Google well that's
why I began especially I love it because
he's a contrarian voice I the fact that
now he's being criticized is he's
looking like a republican running
Twitter how many freaking Democrat
billionaires run media Outlets as soon
as that happens you take over the
Washington Post you take over you run
the New York Times local newspapers as
long as you're a Democrat or a liberal
it's perfectly acceptable it's the way
it should be but if you're a republican
you cannot run a media Outlet if you're
a republican according to the media
Jason but the bolt Elam wasn't super
political on Twitter until Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren started
attacking him for no reason then others
followed of all the dues they would have
could have attacked they chose the guy
most capable of helping government solve
problems strong uh strengths Choice
several other major Democratic
politicians attacked me too all around
the same time it was coordinated outside
of party leadership and Independence
like a mansion they are all essentially
they are essentially actors on the
political stage not directors or
scriptwriters do you agree with them yes
and look I think Elon Musk is the best
counterpuncher in America
Elon Musk knows how to fight back and he
doesn't
and he's very witty and good at it
Donald Trump could learn a few lessons
from that Donald Trump when he counter
punches off and ends up hitting himself
in the chin uh his own shin so I there's
a lot about Elon Musk I like but again
my bigger Point here is
I'm going to continue to tweet as long
as Twitter exists I'll continue to use
that as a form to get my message out but
there's life is so much bigger than
social media
Ari I think you're being a little bit
naive and you know of course there's
life more than social media but when
you're trying to have a voice without
people silencing you you kind of need
other options and I like what happened
yesterday with Tim Cook and Elon Musk
getting together I think Elon Musk even
responded to Tim Cook what uh uh or he
said something about he was at the Apple
headquarters
and he tweeted about that and then even
yesterday when they interviewed Sam
bankman freed uh at New York Times uh
and uh at the same event Reid Hastings
was interviewed and they said hey so
what do you think about Elon Musk I
think he is the biggest genius creative
in the world he says he has a different
style of leading I have a different
style of leading but I think he's a
genius I think he's good I think we have
to be a little bit more patient with
what he's I was very surprised for Reed
Hastings to say that and read Hastings I
gave I think gave three million dollars
to uh Newsome or somebody and you know
he he he's a major contributor to the
left himself so for him to say those
words about Elon was great to see and
now Tim cook's position you know where
they're not planning on taking Twitter
off uh Apple's app all the other stuff
uh it's great to see I think you need
opposition that's not what I'm saying I
think we need opposition very simple I
totally agree with you yeah that's that
that's what I okay but I guess if I were
to give advice to a president I would
Tell The President don't tweet and don't
look at Twitter do you see what Trump
said yesterday so he said he had no
plans of coming back to Twitter he's
going to stay on truth so you think
that's the right that's a financial move
because he has no choice because it's
the same truth yeah yeah but I said can
I go ahead can I ask one follow-up about
media in general back to the that Reagan
speech you gave a few months ago about
your book I mean essentially that's what
this is about you talked about media
bias and they're no longer journalists
they're more activists and you gave the
analogy of you know there's uh in the
White House Press briefing room there's
for every 12 Democrats there's one
Republican you know this kind of stuff
um I I admit it I used to only watch
MSNBC and see it and I would watch Fox
Business we need to fix it so that well
I'm being fixed I've been neutered
um but we talk about this all the time
but getting a mixed media diet right
like if you watch CNN watch Fox a little
bit and contrarian views different
viewpoints and don't just listen to the
mainstream Media Watch podcasts and
watch this and like fully fully consumed
you know I I like watching this uh
looking at this all size media bias
chart you familiar with this stuff you
pull that up what media Outlets I think
we could all fairly state that CNN MSNBC
ABC NBC they're on the left no doubt
Fox uh Newsmax oan you know daily wire
even they're on the right we all know
this where do you find your your Center
these days who do you think is really
playing the center actually being the
old school Walter Cronkite just give me
the news nobody who do you trust these
days let me put it this way I think the
best show in in on the air of anybody is
Fox News six o'clock with Brett Bear but
Bear's a beast that is a old-fashioned
solid news show the reporters who go
from the White House lawn or the
treasury Department or LA
they're playing it right down the middle
and giving you the new straight and it's
an hour long as opposed to the networks
which are 30 minutes long so that's to
me the most subjective best show on the
air of course Fox at night was Sean and
Laura Etc that's opinion TV
um but you know what I do and this is
thanks to Twitter in large part I follow
reporters left and right and so I'm
constantly getting deluged with this
view that view this news that news but I
also know how to read a story in the New
York Times and see the bias right away
and I barely read the New York Times
anymore there's some things I'll read
um but you're you're a professional most
average Americans they don't know
they're not in depth you know all right
is this a bias report is it not I don't
know they're just and I hear it all the
time from people where can I go to get
the new straight right I don't have
enough time and you know somebody like
me I'm a news consumer so I spend time
doing this stuff I watch CNN in the
morning I watch Fox later in the day
this is literally your life and your
business but the average working
American that working nine to five they
got bills to pay they're living paycheck
to paycheck they're just like all right
what's going on today let me watch the
news for a half hour right and they've
put on the TV or they read an article
whatever and that's what they got and my
complaint and this is one of the reasons
I wrote my book is too many mainstream
media reporters especially in the air of
trump turned themselves into anti Trump
activists right that's what they thought
journalism was about was getting rid of
Donald Trump instead of reporting it
straight fair to the middle about Donald
Trump and critics of Donald Trump
sorry what can be done about that
you know what I wrote in my book is that
I really hope that conservatives go into
journalism schools and the journalism
schools have to really attract
conservative thought it goes back to
your point about diversity it's not
about the chromosomes or the makeup of a
class or what skin somebody has it's
about diversity of thought how many
people own guns who go to journalism
School how many people who pray every
day go to journalism school yeah
journalism schools just don't represent
the breadth and depth of America which
means newsrooms don't
so I don't think it'll ever fix itself
until the media legitimately and
intellectually and happily welcomes
conservatives into their ranks but they
don't seem to want to do it because
those people are alien look at what
they're doing at Elon Musk you cannot
own Twitter if you're a known Republican
one more follow-up what percentage of
journalists writers contributors
whatever are college educated Democrats
yeah but it's a big theme of my book
that the fundamental flaw of Journalism
today is its college-educated Democrats
writing for fellow college-educated
Democrats I cite a poll that showed if
you're a Democrat with a high school
diploma
the Press doesn't understand you you
think Independence High School diploma
or college degree the Press doesn't
understand you for all Republicans you
think the Press doesn't understand the
only group of Americans who said to the
Gallup organization that they think that
the Press understands their life our
college-educated Democrats the Press is
now in a cocoon they have driven
themselves into this little small narrow
ideological cul-de-sac that they know
how to go around in the cul-de-sac but
they don't understand America do they
recognize that though
no no because you're too like-minded
they're newsrooms they're management
everybody's cut from the same cloth and
then they think there's something wrong
with their customers it's the only
business I know that's losing customers
losing money and instead of saying
what's wrong with us they say what's
wrong with our customers and then they
continue to lose customers of course you
brought up such a good point such a good
point you said someone asked you a
question and said that Reagan they said
like well you know if there's so much
money in the media that you know they
just get they got to make their money
and you said well because that's because
they're not relying on corporate
advertisers as much anymore and it's a
subscription-based model and you gave
the metaphor the story of one time the
New York Times printed a favorable story
about Donald Trump and their subscribers
like what the are you doing and we're
gonna unsubscribe I think they lost
their most subscribers ever the next day
and they changed the headline on the
story so if you're if you're reliant on
subscribers right you're gonna be just
Reliant to their their their opinions
and their emotions rather than actual
advertisers that want to make money
that's overwhelmingly what's happened to
the print press damn that and it's
happened on TV too because people have
sorted themselves
conservatives tend to watch the stuff
that reinforces their views liberals
watch the stuff that tends to reinforce
their views so you don't want to piss
off your readers or your viewers your
base right but but this is this is also
what we haven't seen yet and I think
it's going to take a decade or maybe
even two to see is the power of
podcasters I think it's going to be
going in a complete different direction
the next decade or two where a lot of
these guys you think people are getting
numbers right now we haven't even seen
people having 100 million subscriber
channels yet wait till people have 100
million subscriber Channel and they're
doing a clip every clip they're doing
they're getting 14 million views 18
million views you you lose the game so
this race of 10 or 20 years it's it's a
it's going to be a very media is going
to be a very very different game the
next 10 to 20 years and they're scared
shitless they have to make the right
adjustments they have to understand how
to be straight up I think one thing I'm
most excited about with Twitter is he
lost 750 million dollars of a
advertising per year because fifty
percent of top 100 advertisers dropped
off that's a big number
and to replace that 750 million dollars
all he needs
is 7.7 million people out of his you
know 250 million active followers to pay
eight bucks a month if 7.7 million
people on Twitter pay eight bucks a
month he no longer needs those 750
million dollars that are advertisers I'm
willing to say if 30 million people pay
eight bucks a month on Twitter it's game
over he doesn't have to bow down to Big
Pharma he doesn't have to bow down to
nobody he becomes the biggest threat in
everybody's business big Pharma one of
these big advertisers are worried the
fact that they may not need their money
imagine you have money to pay to
companies and they're like yeah we don't
want your money he's like what do you
mean you don't want my money I've been
able to buy you for a long time with
your opinions because I can I can't do
it anymore no we don't want your money
oh my God it's like uh you know when a
22 year old girl is like oh look I can't
get anything I want my looks honestly
it's like hey it's kind of changes well
that doesn't work anymore I actually
have to have some substance these big
Pharma companies are going to be sitting
there saying not just big Pharma a lot
of these other advertisers saying man we
are no longer attractive the way we used
to be 10 years years ago games about to
change my opinion folks if you're
watching this we're gonna put the link
below to Ari's book that just came out
in July called deception snobbery and
bias uh let's make sure we put it in the
chat as well as in the description for
you to be able to order this book and
obviously based on what he said he's a
die-hard fan of Twitter we'll put the
link on Twitter as well send a message
to him Ari appreciate you for coming out
this was fantastic really enjoyed
talking to you and uh hopefully we'll do
it another one as the election gets a
little closer now you guys are great and
you're right about the future and
podcasts they are changing the
Communications business yeah well with
that being said please subscribe to the
pbd podcast guys subscribe to value
table and subscribe to our refleischers
Channel at Ari Fleischer on Twitter
there it is okay that's a great channel
before it goes away later on today we
have uh uh we have a um
later on today we'll have Andrew Schultz
on a podcast later on today take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye